-It's time for
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
Here we go, everybody.
-♪ Hashtags ♪
♪♪
♪ Hashtags ♪
-This week, I sent out
the hashtag #MyWorstCar
and asked you guys to tell us
a funny or weird story
about a bad car that you owned.
We've done this hashtag before,
and it was so fun
we wanted to do it again.
Within minutes
of sending it out,
it was a trending topic
in the US,
so thank you for playing along.
And now I thought I'd share
some of my favorite
MyWorstCar tweets from you guys.
Here we go. This first one's
from @UTJonesy.
They say...
[ Laughter, cheering ]
You take it.
This next one's from
@kaitertots. She says...
[ Laughter, applause ]
That's bad. Well...
This next one is from
@boogsrocks. She says...
[ Laughter, applause ]
Sucks to be them.
Oh, it's me.
Next one's from @GuidelinesRUs.
He said...
[ Laughter, applause ]
I -- I have to. I just...
This is amazing what happened.
This next one is from @JWButta.
He says...
[ Laughter, cheering ]
-Yes!
-That's...
That's a good dad hack.
This next one's from
@HansHoefer. He said...
[ Laughter, applause ]
This next one's from
@janelleintx. She said...
[ Laughter, cheering ]
This last one's from
@GlassHeart5. She said...
[ Laughter ]
There you have it.
Those were our
"Tonight Show Hastags."
To check out more
of our favorites, go to...